By now, I'm sure you have recognized that an operating system is a complex
software system. Especially the protocol stack that
sits within an operating system is several hundred
thousand lines of code. And developing such
a complex software system, in general, Protocol stack
in particular, to meet specs and also
deliver very good performance, is no mean challenge.
Let's skip over to the other side of the fence and see how complex hardware
systems for example, a CPU chip like this one with billions of
transistors on it, is built. [UNKNOWN] technology uses
component based approach to building large and complex hardware systems.
Can we mimic the same method for building large
complex software systems? That is, rather than start with a clean slate. Can
we reuse software components? It's very tempting
since component based design will be easier
to test and optimize at an individual component level and also it'll allow
for easy evolution and extension through the
illusion and the leash and of components.
The idea of component based design is
orthogonal to the structure of the operating system
that we've seen in previous lessons. Be it
a monolithic kernel or a microkernel based design,
the idea of component based design can be
applied to each subsystem within an operating system.
Of course, there are challenges. Can this lead
to inefficiencies in performance due to the additional
component level of function calls? Could it lead to loss of locality when we
cross boundaries of components? Could it lead
to unnecessary redundancies, such as copying, et cetera?
Is it possible to get the advantages
of component based design without losing performance? The
short answer is' yes' if you can
put theory and practice together. We will explore
this topic more in this lesson. The
idea is to synthesize Network Protocol Stack from
components. How do we do that? But that's what were going to see in this lesson.
And in this lesson, kernel's ensemble project
is used as a backdrop to illustrate how
to build complex systems by using components.
And using a component based approach to putting
together a large complex hardware system.